*bruit de clochette venant de son pull*
Yes ! C'est moi qui fais ce bruit !
ça va durer pendant toute la vidéo..
Pour changer un peu de mon appart, voici un très beau décor de noël.
Que j'ai euh... pas fais moi même.
Là dans l'image il y a deux Norman.
Il y a moi et il y aussi cette fameuse espèce de sapin, qui malheureusement pour moi s'appelle également Nordmann.
Et pourquoi on ferait pas plutôt Nordmann fait des vidéos ?
Oh!
Je suis occupé là, j'ai pas le temps
Bonjour mes petits conifères, je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais quand t'es un sapin et que t'as grandi en pleine nature avec tes potes.
C'est toujours un plaisir d’être coupé pour noël. Fô...ret. ahahah
Oh! je te parle là ! Bah quoi c'est à mon tour un peu ! Ça c'est ma place ! T'as un problème?
Tu te calme, tu me rends ma place.
Aie aie ok ok stop aie, ok stop j’arrête.
Bref, noël tous les ans c'est un moment magique.
Hein ça c'est clair, par contre que t'ai 10 ans, 20 ans, 30 ans ou plus.
Tu le vis pas exactement de la même manière .
Donc voici noël selon nos âges, tout simplement.
Enfin c'est le même titre que la vidéo en fait
Noël selon nos âges
10 ans
En fait à noël quand t'es enfant t'as rien à faire. Juste tu commandes et tout arrive direct.
Bah ouais.
En fait les gens ils se transforment, bah en Deliveroo et Amazon quoi...
j'suis pas d'accord avec toi tonton, c'est juste des gens qui m'aiment, c'est tout.
ouais... c'est sûr.
tiens ma petite chérie
merci 4,1/5
30 ans
Oh putain! j'le sens pas la je sais pas faire le père noël, je l'ai pas répété, je sais pas.
Mais si si si tout le monde c'est faire le père noël, aller ça va aller t'inquiètes .
Voilà mets ta barbe, aller aller aller hop.
Euh... euh bonjour…
Euh… moi j'suis le père noël en fait…
Et en fait euh... enfin... c'est quoi? je viens du pôle?
Je viens du pôle nord et... ça va?!
*Pleure*
T’inquiètes pas tonton on t'aime quand même. On a compris que tu voulais copier le père noël.
Oh putain je suis une merde.
80 ans
Alors ! qui veut la dernière part de buche? papy ? papy?
Non allez y de toute façon euh... je pense que ça va être mon dernier noël
Ouai je suis pas éternel. Hein Dimitri.
Mais au moins je vais être enterré à coté de mamie.
Bah du coup j'vais prendre un petit peu de vin aussi et aussi un petit peu de fois gras
Si je peux avoir ça du saumon (bien sûr) et Enzo ton drone! s'il te plait!
Enzo le drone! ouai le drone. Apporte le drone a papy ! apporte le s'il te plait oh!
Il va crever apporte!
10 ans
*musique de suspense*
Ok les cadeaux sont par ici.
Bien joué
Qu'est ce que vous faites là les enfants?
Euh... on cherchait les cadeaux de noël.
Mais on est en septembre?
Vous faites trop pitié.
20 ans
Vin blanc, vin rouge et liqueur.
Mais attend t'es sérieux la mec?!
C'est noël qu'on fête hein, pas autre chose !
Bah ouai enfin.
Ok alors tequila et Get 27.
OUHHH!!! COMA ÉTHYLIQUE COMA ÉTHYLIQUE, COMA ÉTHYLIQUE!!!!!
40 ans
Des places pour Disneyland, un bmx, un banc pour fumer des oinj (joints).
Bon Michel ça va pas du tout là, t'es en pleine crise de la quarantaine.
Ok!?
Donc on va refaire ta liste ensemble, hein alors, déjà une crème anti ride.
Une boite de lexomile.
Euh... souscrire à une assurance vie, hein faut bien commencer un jour.
*pleure*
Michel
*Pleure*
Quel métier de merde
10 ans
c'est moi qui fais le sapin, Non c'est moi qui fais le sapin
non c'est moi
j'l'ai dis la première déso
20 ans
Bon les gars cette année avec les études j'ai pas beaucoup de thunes pour noël
mais j'me suis quand même occupé du sapin
Bah moi j'me suis occupé du feu
Et moi de la bûche
ça va être énorme
40 ans
Chéri
T'as pensé au sapin comme prévu?
bah en fait j'm'y suis pris un peu tard mais euh...
voilà voilà
Tu te fous de ma gueule là ?
ah ba nan heu normalement selon la bible heu Saint Nicolas il avait un arbre comme ça hein heu...
*pleurs d'enfants*
Et voilà les enfants chialent maintenant t'es content?
Mais ils ont qu'à imaginer les enfants! hein
C'est quand même un jardiland
20 ans
Bon tout le monde a bien respecté la règle: pas plus de 5euros le cadeau comme ça on est tous pareil
Aller
3,2,1
Bon ba on peut se dire que c'est de la merde
Ouai
C'est le pire noël de ma vie
10 ans
Alors les enfants qui va ouvrir ses beaux cadeaux ?
Moi !
Et après qui va manger un bon repas ?
Et après qui va aller à la messe de minuit ?
ça se fait pas pour le petit jésus
Et le petit agneau
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, et n'oubliez pas que finalement, quand vient noël
on dévient tous de grands enfants
Merci ! merci mon public que j'ai rajouté au montage, hein
Stop
Reprenez
Si vous voulez me faire un cadeau pour noël, mettez tout simplement un petit (pouce) to the top (en l'air) à cette vidéo
Et éventuellement, vous pouvez aussi cliquer sur la petite  cloche pour recevoir les notifications afin d'être prévenu quand je sors une nouvelle vidéo
Ciao
PomPomPom, tiens Norman prends les 2 cadeaux
Oooh merci ça me fait trop plaisir
Tous ça pour moi
Ba non du con c'est pour tes neveux et tes nièces
T'as 30ans j'te rappelle
Donc toi, t'as des chaussettes
YES !
*Musique*